art is neither right or left and when I
look at our today I see just one voice
being heard I mean I believe the
Republican Party or conservatives or
whatever you want to call them
libertarians have a great message they
just don't have anyone telling you
almost have to take a step back and
question why that is and when you start
doing that you start seeing how all the
cogs and wheels turn in such a way to
where if you decide you want to be a
creative you're almost pushed into the
left towards the left it's almost if you
want to be a punk you go to hot topics
they have a punk rock kid you want to be
a rockabilly they got a rockabilly kid
it's like a goth a goth kid and I mean
all the it just it turns into a joke at
the end of the day everyone's rebelling
the same way I'm tired of people
defining who I am
my name is sable I'm an artist people
call me a conservative street artist I
do this this art that I put out on the
street people ask me why it's the
cheapest way to get your word out there
you know it just happens to turn into
what they call street art I guess when
you consider how many artists out there
are leftist it's a huge percentage so
right off the bat you know that kind of
sets me apart I mean if we were a field
of cows you'd have 20 on this side one
on this one and that kind of made it
possible for someone with mediocre
skills to stand out this is a fact in
you [ __ ] piece I was at a prop 8 rally
two gay men were creating signs and I
heard one of them say to the other we
[ __ ] are the new [ __ ] and I was like
holy crap that's a very bold statement
for someone to say so I asked him to
elaborate and he said exactly what I
knew he was going to say please had that
gay community back the black man for
president but the black community didn't
back the gay community against prop 8
every time someone comes into my
apartment the first thought is wow is he
a racist Rossio homophobe as i knew
there's the case I mean this heads
contest and the thing about him this
piece is you can actually take the
stencil off and it works as a stencil
and in the back you'll see are all these
hidden flowers it's kind of like it's
the beauty behind these people kind of a
thing but when you put the stencil back
on all you really see how the bumps
bruises and cuts when they're getting
beat up this is the Obama drones one of
the Obama drones I got that together
when I was in Denver
I did this Ted Cruz piece and from that
I kind of gained a bit of independence
as I got a couple of bucks in my pocket
and things kind of took off for me
another Obama drone the paltrow when
when Obama is here fundraising Rick
Perry's mug shot
it's April 15th [ __ ] better have my
money that worked out really well I
think someone threatened to throw me in
jail my political beliefs are SEC Reagan
said man the scariest thing is when
someone comes as I'm with the government
I'm here to help you people will say all
there's always been you know
conservative artists that may be true
but they weren't mean it's like you know
my focus was to be mean nasty and just
as bad as Bill Maher or anyone else and
in I'd like to think I was fairly good
at it you may ask well why don't I do a
poster against a Republican the answer
that I always come up with is because
90% of the artists are we going to do
that it's like why do I want to jump in
but uh I mean if a Republican artist
does something that's not artist but
politicians or something it's completely
gross then of course I'll jump on them
it's like I mean I'm probably going to
jump on Jeb Bush I don't want to see
another Bush in office at first you get
death threats I like that you get
reactions and I like it when someone
actually goes out of their way to insult
me or they have a strong opinion of what
what I did because that tells me there's
something successful about the piece so
why is it important it's important
because it's the other side of the
narrative that's just not being spoken
and it's important because somewheres
down the line Republicans forgot or
conservatives forgotten the importance
of art and the ability to push your
message in a way that resonates with the
youth if you get a young person to smoke
Marlboro when they're young
a pretty good chance they're going to be
smoking it on their own
works the same way with politics there's
something about having it out on the
street it's it's illegal it's dangerous
adrenaline pumps there's just something
about strategically placing your art
where the eyes are and where hands can't
reach it and it makes the news I can't
tell you why it makes the news and a
blog doesn't but sometimes blogs do as
well but you know III think it intrigues
them that someone who's not a leftist is
doing this out on the street i I've
never hit someone's house I never I
don't go out of my way to screw up
people's property at all if I feel it's
going to hurt someone in any way I
definitely won't do it and that makes it
that much more likely it's going to make
news yeah yeah leftist thinking's not
never going to change
it's I don't always be leftist out there
they'll still be trying to take your
guns they'll still be infiltrating
schools they'll still be infiltrating
Hollywood television music the arts
they're never going to go away
government screwed up and it's always
going to be screwed up you have a
certain government class out there be it
right or left there's always something
to hit